How does a cancer arise?
When I started my research, no one could possibly tell you
how that problem might be solved.
And yet,
within a few years, it was solved,
beginning with something as humble as a chicken virus.
We've come an extraordinary long way in our
understanding of cancer in the span of my career,
which is 48 years or so,
but we've faced very daunting
challenges.
We are far from home free,
and it's going to take an unanticipated,
unpredictable breakthrough,
I think,
to get us home free.
In fact,
I'm a bit of a skeptic.
I'm not sure we will ever cure metastatic cancer
uniformly.
I believe that the way we will ultimately manage cancer is by prevention.
That's a lesson we learn from microbiology.
Vaccines are better than antibiotics,
right?
You get resistance to antibiotics, that's become a major plague in
humankind,
but vaccines prevent the infection to begin with.
We know that we can prevent a lot of lung cancer by eliminating
the use of tobacco. We know that we can prevent a
lot of skin cancer by limiting exposure to the ultraviolet light in sun.
We know that we can prevent liver cancer by vaccinating against
hepatitis viruses.
We know that we can prevent cervical cancer by vaccinating against
another virus.
Ultimately,
we could vanquish cancer by prevention.
But we know so little about what causes cancer.
We do not know what causes breast cancer,
colon cancer,
pancreatic cancer,
ovarian cancer, some of the major killers, we simply do not know what causes them.
And it is a very difficult form of research.
So I like to sound a cautionary note that we may
never conquer this disease completely with therapeutics.
We will definitely improve how well we do,
but we will not conquer the disease completely.
We can conquer it ultimately through prevention.